I really wanted Monsters Inc part two
because I was winning I liked the
character of boo and I want I thought
it'd be cool if like boo came back and
she was like in her 20s or something
like that and you know and then she
falls in love with you know Sullivan
really weird a sequel Hey Pixar fans my
name is Ryan Wright and I'm Michele Q
fill it in for Jerry welcome two reasons
to see where we give you reasons to see
and not to see my serves University so
let's go to school you monster reason to
see number one it's a fresh pretty cool
I enjoyed this movie more than I thought
I did
oh wait a minute I'm sweeter I I enjoyed
this movie more than I thought I would
it was surprisingly fresh like I I saw
the trailers for this and I thought it
was gonna be another dumb installment
and Pixar
yeah I thought was gonna be one of
Pixar's you know disappointing movies I
had faith in this maybe from the get-go
because of the fact that I didn't feel
like it was moving against sequel out
there like for cars to I felt like it
was made in the spirit of Monsters Inc
because of how loved that movie is I
don't know might go to the bathroom how
do any of them go the bad thing will it
make sense of Sullivan go these guys so
much hair that it just doesn't look like
pubic hair just blends in with the rest
of you here doesn't have anything to do
with being I'm just saying you might
have a penis you just can't see it
because there's so much hair there maybe
they do external fertilization but what
about you know Mike I mean he just has a
head in an eyeball
you're just an eyeball like how can you
possibly go to the back I mean what does
he do they eat but maybe he was in the
bathroom what happens i I don't know
they're mobsters look this is beside the
point you're getting off-topic Michele
this is a fresh freak that's what's hard
to do with prequels especially when you
know it like an x-men first class they
took a whole bunch of different actors
and they put them into prequel so it's
easier to make it feel fresh but when
you're taking like the same two cast
members and the same two characters
putting them in the prequel it's hard to
make it feel like oh this is exciting
ooh what's gonna happen next or oh my
god I hope they make it and they manage
to make you generate those feelings
while you're watching this film nice
because they did put in some throwbacks
like there's a Randall who's in there
yeah there's more other you know Easter
eggs there for you yeah there's a couple
I don't want to give them away but
they're so nice and cool I thought it's
little weird you know seeing them take
place on monsters University you know to
see them back in college and stuff what
was cool is that the personalities felt
fresh you felt like you were getting to
know them and you know it wasn't like
okay yeah there's the obvious part where
Mike and Sulley are not getting along at
first and what's funny is I was watching
those moments going oh that's gonna piss
Sully off ooh that's gonna piss Mike off
I wasn't there thinking they're gonna
get along one day everything's gonna
work out fine like you get so pulled
into the story the stories being told so
well in the character development so
well that you forget about the original
the way that they dislike each other is
so authentic that it's like you're not
thinking like how how could they dislike
each other these guys are best pals like
no you believe it although it takes you
know some cliche routes I really do like
the way how the last half-hour plays out
oh yeah the last half-hour it was more
in tune with the original monsters name
but that's what's cool is like it's a
great prequel because it starts off
completely different vibe in tone than
Monsters Inc but as it goes it does
become part of the world that were more
familiar with towards the end of the
movie and it also has a fresh twist on
what can be rather predictable movie and
the like especially that last half hour
yeah
really enjoyed that because I was
thinking that it was gonna be kind of
predictable I was like oh this is oh I
mean it's predictable but I guess I can
get on board with it and I really liked
it that they didn't go that route and
they did something different and it was
like ah yes thank goodness there's
something even more enjoyable than the
predictions of reasons to see number two
my end Sully they managed to keep them
at the core of what we love about them
but also make them different and yet
their chemistry is still awesome
together still maintain that great
chemists even when they're not getting
along they still have great chemistry
it's like we said earlier you believe it
it's cool you know it's great to see
that same kind of spirit the actors can
make them believable as both archenemies
and best friends yeah when they first
meet you feel that sense of like oh this
is the first time they're meeting and it
feels fresh it doesn't feel forced and
they're so funny together too especially
Mike and what was cool was in the first
one was more about Sully this one they
made Mike more of the lead character I
thought like well Mike's more of the
comic relief are they gonna pull this
off and they pull it off very well like
he was a great lead character and it was
cool to see him as a guy who's aspiring
to be a monster and there's a lot of
great life lessons in this movie it's
funny because they end almost every
sentence with but that's like how a
monster is a monster a monster they are
use the word monster but there's there's
great life lessons that these guys are
always learning that I think are great
messages for everybody not just kids but
for anybody who wants to accomplish
anything I'm gonna live for who wants to
be anything it's great messages Mike and
Sulley here can appeal to both little
kids as well as adults who are watching
this movie there's a different way of
viewing for each age group but each age
group I think is gonna be really
satisfied with what they're watching I
really like the growth that both of them
have to go through it seems like it
would be an obvious art but they'd
actually take it to another exponential
level that people might not actually
expect to see it really affected me
deep inside it cuz looks like damn like
that's so true so many people can relate
to this when you guys watch it you'll
totally understand what I'm talking
about yeah it's a homoerotic
relationship reason to see number three
the animation when I saw the trailer I
wasn't impressed with the animation I'm
like this just looks like another
cartoon to me but the animation is so
good and so detailed like you don't get
distracted watching it going oh they're
just a bunch of weird characters like
they all have personality they'll have
life the details of the graphics are
awesome the monsters are detailed I like
that it's the monsters are not scary to
the point where they're gonna terrify
you for kids by then to see except the
one headmistress or whatever her name is
she was yeah but she's kind of semi
antagonist in this movie yeah she's
pretty creepy just even from like the
buildings and every single monster and
it just was flushed out so well I loved
the details of all of them especially
Sully's PB here you know what I think of
Pixar's I think of a certain caliber I
have certain expectation of our
animation and really debate I don't
think they ever failed on my
expectations of it because Pixar is
always that one animation that's just
above all of the other Animation Studios
what about Toy Story that's pig's eye
I'm kidding people I'm never
disappointed with Pixar's animation and
if you're looking forward to that
animation you're gonna be totally
satisfied it's like an orgasm this is
the most orgasmic children's movie I've
ever seen revisiting number four pixar
short film as you know before every
movie of Pixar's there's always a short
film they make and they made one that I
thought was very unique because it was
interesting how it was a blend of both
the animation and real life was it was a
real life yeah because the animation
looks so good it was my frenemy they had
some parts real life and then they put a
filter over it to make it look a little
bit more animated which at first I'll be
honest I was like why is this looking so
why did they include real life like
you're expecting and ever
short so I was thinking like what are we
gonna do with this at the beginning I
was like it this is kind of weird I
guess I'll I'll see what happens
and you know um to work when I actually
was all said and done I actually really
enjoyed it I thought it was really cute
yeah I don't want to get the film away
for you cuz it's just a short film it's
about an umbrella and they managed to
make a story about an umbrella rather
enjoyable to why it's kinda like a sight
like a silent film you know it's alders
yeah there's almost like a little bit of
a minor talks in it but I thought it was
one of their most unique short films
yeah really nice I enjoyed it yeah
definitely different vibe than what we
normally get with pigs are definitely we
reason to see number five new monsters
they have a lot of great characters in
there too like a lot of great side
characters I really like the show on the
trailer the one monster is like a head
with two arms yeah I think that's uh
it's Charlie Day from It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia I'm pretty sure that's
him we can't guarantee it funny show
watch it kids that monster was cool and
there's and like I even like the college
kind of dicks they're like they're all
the cool monsters they're very inventive
and in a lot of their own ways and and
another thing too
you root for Mike and Sully's team yeah
you root for their team and you like the
monsters in there and you embrace their
uniqueness as time goes on I think in
this movie you see more of the variety
of monsters in the world oh yeah I think
I thought it was really cool to see you
know all the different kinds of monsters
and they really expanded that world
reasons not to see not as original yeah
one of them disappointing parts of this
movie to me was especially in the in
like the first half of the film was this
I like I've seen this movie a billion
times before us at this time it's with
monsters and the jokes are better I've
seen that you know formula play out
before so to see this film and to know
that it's Pixar and especially coming
off of Monsters Inc which I love
Monsters Inc one of my most favorite
Pixar movies ever I cry almost every
time I watch that movie kitty
remember that do you remember that yeah
the monsters dick just brought you this
whole original world so you know it's
it's different you Verde
part of the monster world now we're
stepping back into it but the way the
plot unfolds it's not as original as you
know one might expect or what my hope
for but although it's formulaic it's
still a good execution of the formula
and but like I said last half hours or
most of its originality is actually
takes place it does have those college
cliches but ultimately for me it really
didn't bother me that much it was just
kind of like oh I guess I kind of
expected that it didn't ruin the movie
for me or really detract from it it was
I still was able to really fairly enjoy
the movie
yeah it's like a good college movie for
kids you know the main audience I think
is for kids so I thought of senior
citizens okay senior citizens so you
know you have kids going wait a second
this is a cliche college movie you know
you're just gonna have more of the
adults failing that way but at the same
time it was cute to see that applied in
the monster world and I think that's
worth it you get that original the
originality from and there's stuff for
adults too like when Mike is chugging on
the beer bomb a lot of the female
monsters are showing their boobs
there's my wrestling yeah now I was
having crazy you know LSD drug trips and
stuff oh yeah that was probably the best
part of the best part was when they were
dancing on E oh yeah oh yeah and then
and then like night they take split ends
with nine months later and mike has like
children because he had sex with someone
he didn't really I don't know how he had
sex he's just no I ball but he managed
to do it
he I [ __ ] to them he I [ __ ] up that's
what he does that's how he gets laid
with that woman who I wish they share
how we met Cecilia yeah Cecilia the
woman from the original would like all
that's in the snake hair yeah because
that would have been cool how does he
have sex with her no I don't think they
really talk of these are questions Pixar
do not ask themselves or answered for us
maybe they ask themselves that they just
and forth no okay that's what Monsters
Inc 3 is for were Lions consensus
enjoyable time for the family is the
reason a see monsters University an
enjoyable time for the family is the
reason to see monsters University yeah
you know it's not one of Pixar's best
but it's certainly a pretty good I would
say it's borderline really good Michelle
this another great Pixar movies reason
to see monsters University another great
Pixar movie is a reason to see you
monsters University for me have falls
under the category of great Pixar movies
it's fun to watch it's great for all
ages and it's enjoyable and it has that
great Pixar spirit that I love alright
guys thanks for checking out our show
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us what is
your favorite Pixar movie does monsters
University match up there
what is it just tell us we would like to
know and if you want to check out more
episodes of furries in the sea
click the link right here and if you
want to go ahead and follow us on
facebook click the link right here and
if you want to follow us on Twitter
click the link right here and most
importantly remember to click that box
right here yeah subscribe Ryan and
Michelle's University yeah
welcome to our world you'll be blown
away ha she said blown yeah you can blow
my monster and it's University which are
my balls just to be clear kind of wine
huh miscommunicate been up for that
class yeah yeah like Scullion miss Foley
this film stars Mulder and Scully like
Sully I have blue pubic hair it's almost
like boob a good maker to maker it's the
air around the Pooh its pooh big air
you